معنا الان من حيفا ايهاب جبارين الكاتب
المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي اهلا بك استاذ
ايهاب تاكيدات ان كان من الحرس الثوري
الايراني الجهات الايرانيه وايضا جهات
اخرى بما جرى بحي المزه بدمشق ولكن هناك
صمت اسرائيلي تفسير هذا الصمت الاسرائيلي
بخصوص هذه الغاره على المزه بدمشق حتى
اللحظه نعم تحياتي استاذه زدها وصباح
الخير بطبيعه الحال هذا الصمت هو
استراتيجيه اس تعتمدها في كل مره يكون
هنالك اغتيالات لعده اسباب بدايه يعني
الامر الاول والمطبق هو في نهايه المطاف
هي لا تريد ان ان يكون هنالك ردود فعل
مبيته مباشره اتجاهها او اتجاه يعني
استهدافات اسرائيليه في المقام الاول في
كل تواجدهم في الخارج هذا الامر الاول
المطبق ولكن كذلك في نهايه المطاف هذا ما
يسمى ب سياسه التعتيم التي تعتمدها
اسرائيل هذه السياسه تاتي كذلك يعني في في
سياق العمل ضمن المن المطقه الماديه
بالذات عندما يكون هنالك استهدافات ل
سيادات دول اخرى كالذي يجد في في الفتره
الاخيره ان كان في لبنان في سوريا او في
غيرها كذلك من المناطق هذه هذه الامر
الثاني وكذلك في نهايه المطاف هنا يعني
انا باعتقادي الحديث ليس فقط عن محاوله
لاستدراج ايران بقدر لمحاوله ما وضع
الابهام واستدراج الولايات المده استدراج
ايران الى ماذا استاذ ايهاب استدراج ايران
الى ماذا اقليميه ربما قد تنقض بيمين
نتنياهو من كل الازمه الموجود فيها في
غضون كل هذه الفتره ولكن انا باعتقادي
كذلك هنا محاوله استدراج او محاوله باشاره
اصابع الاتهام كذلك الى الولايات المتحده
هذا يعني كذلك امر وارد يجب ان يخذ بعين
الاعتبار بالذات في
ظل التوترات
الاخيره الايرانيه الامريكيه ان كان في
العراق وغيرها من المناطق يعني هذه احد
الاستراتيجيات التي يعتمدها كذلك
الج الاستخباراتيه الايه سيناريو
الاستدراج حتى وان كان واردا هل اسرائيل
قادره في هذه المرحله على فتح كل هذه
الجبهات في ذات
التوقيت هذا هو النقطه المهمه جدا لانها
موجوده اسرائيل في ازمه حقيقيه اسرائيل
موجوده في ازمه حقيقيه بكل ما يخص الجبهات
السبعه التي اعلن عنها جالانت قبل اسابيع
وبالتالي حاليا وحتى وان كانت تاخذ العتاد
والدعم اللوجستي من الولايات المتحده وان
كانت كذلك يعني الحوثيين هم باداره او
بمواجهه امريكيه مباشره لكن هي ما زالت
تريد على الاقل جهات معينه في داخل هذا
الكابينت وان لم يكن كل هذا الكابينت على
راسهم بنيامين نتنياهو ربما اطراف استخ
امنيه معينه لي ليس كلها كذلك بالتالي
تريد ان ان تقحم بشكل مباشر الولايات
المتحده لانها لا تستطيع باي شكل من
الاشكال
انهاء هذا العدوان وهذه الحرب لوحدها
بصوره حسم حقيقيه باي شكل من الاشكال
الهزيمه الاستراتيجيه بات الكل يتحدث عن
الهزيمه الاستراتيجيه وبدون اي دعم ليس
فقط لوجستي مره اخرى بدون اي دعم يعني
بالجبهات السبعه التي اعلن عنها انا وبدون
اي يعني تصعيد يمكن القول حتى يعني هذا
الدعم في نهايه المطاف سوف يصدر عنه تصعيد
وبدون اي تصعيد لهذه الحاله ف بدون ان نشك
ن اسرائيل الهزيمه اللوجستيه ربما حتى هذا
ما كانت قد تحدث عنه يوس كوهن يوم امس
بانها ربما هذه المره الاولى التي يتوجب
على ان تعلن الهزيمه بشكل مطلق فبالتالي
فقط ان ان يكون هنالك حاله من التصعيد
تشترك فيها الولايات المتحده ربما او ربما
حتى بعض الجهات الاخرى هي حاله النزول من
على الشجره التي يمكن ان تعتمدها اسرائيل
وهذا بالمناسبه ما حولت اصلا القيام فيه
في داخل يعني عندما اغتالت العاروري قبل
اسبوعين ثلاثه هذه كان احد الاستراتيجيات
التي بنى عليها الجانب الامني
الاستخباراتي في اسرائيل ان يكون هنالك
تصعيد يعني موقت ومؤقت في ذات الوقت لمدى
اسبوع او اسبوعين وبعده يكون هنالك حاله
من النزول من على كل الشجرات عبر يعني
المسعى الدبلوماسي ولكن على ما يبدو ان
هذا لم ياتي اكله فبالتالي واضح جدا ان
هنالك تجربه اخرى باعتقادي في محاوله
استدراج حقيقيه كذلك يعني هذا يجب ان نقط
بعين الاعتبار